okay so would you like to know the
exercise that can boost human growth
hormone by seven hundred and seventy one
percent any ideas sprinting sprinting is
one of the most explosive high-intensity
interval training type exercises you can
do it's a short bout of full speed
running okay and I like it because it
gives you a body a maximum stress with
short duration we're only talking 20 to
30 seconds and then you want to rest for
90 seconds okay and then you want to
repeat this and work up to about eight
times I'm gonna put a study down below
you can check out the link so sprinting
could be twice as effective as injecting
human growth hormone and if you add
other things like decrease your stress
level make sure that you're sleeping
better intermittent fasting Kido
you can really spike growth from a big
time so what you want to do is you want
to do a short duration high-intensity
workout with lots of rest and repeat
this because growth hormone is triggered
by the high intensity and the longer the
duration the worse the growth hormone
because you stimulate cortisol and if we
keep the recovery long we can allow this
process to occur because we don't want
to over train the person and of course
if your knees are damaged or you have
some type of issue where you can't do
sprinting you can do this on a bike or
even swimming alright thanks for
watching now I always love getting
feedback from you on these videos so
comment below and tell me what you think